une vraie carbonara au hautbois au moins
la version la version authentique et qui
en a un qui n'utilise en sortant par les
l'italie avec c'est un plat des forces
sympa des forces qui étaient faites par
les chercheurs des chambres dans les
mines et la simple a pas facile parce
que quand même est simple 1 à l'origine
à l'origine de la cabanasse un plan
vraiment cuisson alors en incarnation la
plus important que je vais te montrer
mon plan de travail par exemple on a 1
les gones chalet tu vas nous présente
blessés importants détruit du match
aller mais ce n'est pas du grand chalon
pour faire le coach et à la différence
du monde sur les plus bas c'est un peu
plus grand ok après j'ai un petit
bouquet sopalin tu vas rentrer c'est
très important parce que je vais écoulée
mais le rebond il faut que j'aie
l'érotique après le poivre et je lui qui
est un moulin à poivre
oui est ce que tu peux les sortir oui
bien sûr et récupérer et récupérer les
graines d'accord et tu vas prendre les
comprend une petite poignée cherche un
petit chapeau ni un impôt généreux sur
scène soignée général ai parlé je mets
ça sur mon plan de travail parfait après
moi j'ai déjà les insectes traite avec
le cercle français en cercle s'est passé
c'est pas gênant ok j'ai une eau de l'ue
d'environ d'ailleurs gigue
j'ai également une à une pizza spaghetti
mais par un combat une pensée classique
c'est la faire j'ai une rampe alors
c'est très important
la taille de la rapidité du pecorino
départ mais j'en passe rue il faut
vraiment que le pecorino ils soient les
plus fins possibles la même chose qu'on
va faire on va prendre la cancha
hollywood janin alors ça qu'on va aller
poser directement sur le plan de travail
afin d'en faire alors qu'est ce qu'on va
faire on va prendre un couteau et on va
couper les gones charles oui en juillet
d'accord ah oui donc il faut est-ce que
tout est ce que l'eau est ce que l'on
est bouillante et contre qui
non je n'ai pas misé encore évolué au
ketchup donc on met x 2 pincées de sel
ouais de penser c'est le seul essai de
la cooperl et finalement elle est
facilement possible pas quoi aux grosses
quoi un demi centimètre chef mettre
d'accord alors franchi en plaisantant
que son atp du doigt ce fait attention
chef chef
si on n'a pas de le pecorino de parmesan
avec quoi est-ce qu'on peut remplacer le
fromage solution c'est un peu compliqué
parce que des courants alternatifs
on sort tu peux d'ailleurs été un
classique après si vraiment vous devez
contribuer vous faudra faire avec
autre chaude on peut essayer de faire
avec l'exemple la rencontre d'accord
allait les quitter avec du conte très
sains et 36 mois par exemple d'accord
avec un vieux comté avec un décompte
mais c'est pas la même chose mais il ya
vraiment un niveau qu'il faut voir en
manière de fonctionner comme une copine
et du coup on peut essayer avec du comté
ou un autre comme à jaffa dur qui
sentent bien qu'ils soient en moi un
grand coup en six mois en 28 mois +
allomaniacs non retour
c'est un peu un peu grossi mais je vais
essayer les comptes mais à mon avis ça
pourrait marcher d'accord donc un compte
et un g ça ça marche comme on fait la
cuisine maison alors il ya un autre
petit cerveau qui nous disaient qu'ils
afin bien sûr nos corps enfin du coup il
ya beaucoup de choses qui se passent
dans notre corps parce que on est hyper
excitées et on a la tendance à cuire et
beaucoup plus de qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
on a besoin de manger
dès lors que parce que notre et avant
des messages en visant vas-y ar je pense
que parce que quand on alors là c'est
une bonne astuce de toujours peser les
quantités dépassent au des produits qui
vous réfugiez vous faites comme des
cuisines et parce que m
sinon vous allez déjà trop culinaire
accroc
vous donnez à garder la grosseur des
spaghettis chef alors moi j'utilise
alors les spaghettis l'ingrédient france
école qui focalisent et des spaghetti
qui soit et il ya des manques découvert
je pense que toi tu as des roues mono
oui c'est ça alors c'est juste que mon
sens il faut une banque de sa gaieté qui
cuisent environ en 12 minutes
oui vous avez pu voir là la côte est pas
lisse et de l'espagne et y effectivement
ces éditions cd trafic en bronze
du coup ils sont chargés en amidon et
c'est la maison qui va m'aider à faire
face aux forfaits à prix constants comme
les spaghettis sont cuits ils vont
raid-h et où la rigolade à la pâte et
c'est qu'est ce qui va m'aider à donner
la côte est crémeuse
alors qu'en faire alors encore une
petite étape avant que makoun spaghettis
bien c'est que l'on en prend deux
regarde la quantité des des points jugés
proches louis tu vas bien j'ai prendre
je prends le faut ok et je vais aller
conséquence à oman où une emma peel
d'accord donc on met nos deux poignées
de poivre quelque chose de la casserole
donc sur le plan de travail
moi je voulais pas un moulin points
possibles on n'a pas été trop faim après
papier des accusés alors c'est vrai que
ça sent très bon chef un loader du
poivre et très agréable combien de temps
de cuisson peut être pas gâté alors moi
c'était des douze minutes chef alors
deux minutes du matin six minutes
raconte anne d'accord et je plonge et
puis plongé ok alors je plonge n'est 195
160 g de spaghettis et jeu mais six
minutes sur mon palmer parfait
jean marie paule évite maintenant tu
prend le large
dupont n'a qu'à servir oui là-bas qu'ils
vont me parler comme ça euros une petite
panique à ces vols et hull en juin
ok ok est-ce que je couvre mais
spaghetti chef non pas du tout parce
qu'ils vont évoluer dans l'eau
tranquillement et tu les laisses tu
joues tu les laisses bouillir gentil
vent et tous mes deux fils et tu mets
dix cantons par ailleurs il arrive à 6
minutes ok très bien
enfin wendel ducasse évoque un temps de
chauffe et gérant la pente fatale je
prendrai les botswanais et je le mets à
l'intérieur sans rien ajouter 100 truies
en bourse à rien et les jette
je vais un peu assez assez puissant au
départ à d'accord
donc on est un service et que notre dans
notre source une autre poêle
on vient mettre la pancetta ou le one
chalet que l'on a fait en petit julienne
hockey et une fois que tu as me
l'apprendre sept ans je prends la moitié
du poivre je prendre un bon client un
bouc hier à un public hier un truc de
mon corps et je la leur à de la fin je
rappelle que vous avez la recette parce
que il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
rejoignent là et donc vous avez la
recette
ce qui est sûr le figaro.fr donc on est
en train de faire des spaghettis
carbonara avec le chef étoilé simone
zanoni sur lefigaro.fr vous avez tous
les ingrédients
donc je prends une cuillère de poivre
chef une pierre va poindre batterie que
le mec avec la femme fatale et puis
corentin raux pur ok en fait un peu et
au départ maintenant un peu à ses 120
oui c'est assez fort le pauvre ça sent
très bon ben c'est pour faire comme
l'expliqué avec avec les grandes
chaleurs
mais l'ancien ouvrier qui élève le
bouillant avec le public
il faut conclure trop vite d'accord donc
je rêvais un peu ouais études montrent
qu'en plus de temps et plus voir
qu'aucune forme par est inconsciente a
pu leur mettre un point d'accord à 37
ans est à fulton mouchette à cette
géniale on est un con à la
alors de temps en temps ce mélange et
spaghettis
alors là je suis sur ma pomme ses tares
et les spaghettis que j'ai un petit peu
désuni en cuite ont à traiter pourtant
une chose répond oui je vais essayer
cette alors dès qu'un bateau com - vers
la tuque rang tu prendre les eaux oui et
d'aït ben tu meurs
le jour 2 oui et à le confier par deux
jaunes et le troisième pour le nez
entier las vegas a alors gd on a des
commentaires qui disent que qui espère
que cette carbonara va être à la carte
du georges à leur chef
est-ce que la carbonara et à la carte du
georges alors elle est pas encore de
jambes mais quand nouvelle jungle de
monde
on a toujours un bonheur à l'égard des
gamins concrètes quand même prendre vos
furets envisage d'aller surveiller je
vais surveiller map en chine le groupe à
répondre oui oui le drapeau d'attentes
très très long pas fait alors la balle
quand tu prends cet aspect de la vie et
les échecs
ok et tu commence à prendre corps et 500
grammes des communaux et environ 300 g
de parmesan citta di bona pas tous
utilisés pour l'instant je vais partout
parce que je sais pas je veux j'attends
de voir que moi j'avais mesuré
j'avais peser 100 g je vais corriger ça
donc on prend soixante et soixante à
comment je mette un peu plus écolo que
du parmesan après que c'est plutôt de
vous et vous accompagne tout au
lendemain alors chef je vérifie il me
reste encore une minute sur montagne
mais ne peuvent aller par
en terminale s est pas dans mes chefs
vous mettez à la barre et on a monté la
pièce que la l1 avec en plus un c'est
clair alors ça y est j'ai coupé mon
pecorino j'ai coupé mon parmesan et je
vois que le chef est déjà en train de le
rap est donc et il faut que j'incorpore
bon fromage dans mes oeufs battus
heureux lecteurs
mais oui alors encore un petit exercice
physique parce que chacun de faire je
suis en train de rapper mon parmesan
dans les eaux que j'ai préparé
attention âgées le times qui j'ai le
tanneur des six minutes qui vient pas
comme j'en fais pas cette enquête en
l'être humain
ok ben moi je crois que tu attends à
leur chef
mon commentaire qu'on ne sait pas
comment m voilà ma pancetta ok parfait
elle a besoin de gens sortis la
gouttière qui hockey et je l'aimé foulée
son programme très bien je le rappelle
un tout à l'heure en début de recel
m'avait préparé notre petit sopalin donc
jamais que la moitié de la marche et
ouais ok et je prends une longe la tv
guys et prendre j'ai perdu j'ai pondu
louche d'eau de cuisson
oui et je vais là bas pas de cet
amendement
mais je suis donc il y en a 37 ans est
un peu plus tôt à l'aube nouvelle louche
hockey et la pétanque est ce que je fais
mes gardes
je prends mes seins gâtés ils sont
encore très dur parce qu'ils sont un
outil puissant et hlm et je vais les
remettraient damas 27 ah parce qu'il
rend cuire les spaghettis dans la sauce
très bien donc je l'aimé je les écoute
je les écoute mais le plus fort c'est
très important
ah oui donc il va falloir que je sorte
donc ne versez pas dans l'écumoire un
très important que vous perdez l'eau de
cuisson on garde notre eau de cuisson
samira terre battue sans le puck apl que
les remettre à 37 ans on a un au
spaghetti qui sont égoutter et les
mettre dans la poche étant toujours à ce
toujours le fond à ce chef manque de
l'eau là dedans il faut plus de journaux
depuis son hockey eh ben ça tombe bien
j'en ai gardé sur lesquels ces legs via
la toile depuis hier la personne brdp à
l'eau en cortège excuses à l'aise que
plus à l'aise bouillir consacrent du
temps à cause de l'eau chaude mais
devant des gardiennes à l'égard de bien
mais sera guettée tu vois qu'il commença
maintenant et commence à cuire tous deux
mois avec le pont les goûts j'ai de la
pancetta du poivre en cuir c'est
effectivement ça sent déjà très très bon
et on les voit qu'ils grossissent un
petit peu ok descendez prétend un parfum
suivant un peu trop vite il faut qu'ils
vous m'avez tout le monde alors on
baisse un peu ceux auxquels hs sa valeur
absolue et a alors exactement que tu
continueras grand machin avant que
conformément aux polluants alors j'ai un
commentaire qui dit et pourquoi et
goûter il faut arrêter cette habitude
des goudes égoutter les pâtes sks qu'un
chef et italiens que répondre est-ce
qu'il faut égoutter les pâtes tout
simplement
alors ben oui parce que toi tu as
quelques fois que les
jamais dans mes bons défenseurs alors je
suis en train de finir de pecorino chef
en fait on alors on a on a quelqu'un
d'angleterre qui demande si on peut
utiliser du fromage et dan et dames
cheese ben oui c'est sûr qu'on peut on
peut même dire mais c'est pas la mer
alors chargé j'ai raté mon fromage dans
l'is alors quand je jeune élégant et
avant que apprendre tout mélanger mes
gardes
j'ai fondé une des milieux chutes d'eau
de cuisson et gels hamlet la maison des
jeunes est longue et je mélange tout de
suite derrière
je mettrais bien hautement tchèque
il faut peut-être que je rajoute un peu
de fromage alors ah ouais pourquoi amy
permis beaucoup trop d'eau là à côté de
fromage dedans bon j'ajoute du fromage
alors il faut que j'aie book et est
dégoûté a regretté pour votre reçu son
iphone c'est cuit au moins de maintenir
la pression
est ce qu'une minute est ce que tu te
sens ensuite en scandale bent c'est
encore un petit peu al dente je pense
que ça mérite encore une ou deux minutes
vous chez vous si vous êtes rendu compte
que vos yeux étaient trop liquide vous
rectifié comme moi j'ai mis un peu trop
d'eau apparemment donc eric vous
regardez alors si vous regardez dame et
de talent spaghettis le le mélanger avec
la côté est des spaghettis ils ont déjà
promis chef alors on te voit cuisine et
il y avait beaucoup de gens qui me
disent on 11
bien voir le chef voilà le lay lay
soldano ni ébats en place dans ta
cuisine c'est pour ça que les huit
chalets c'est l'idéal parce qu'il a
remporté cette fois j'ai des grands
c'est vous assez important alors là on a
toujours notre reste de coin de chalets
ou de pantxo l'état qui est sur le
papier sopalin chef est ce que c est ce
que c'est mieux la consistance va mieux
c'est mieux alors alors maintenant red
bien des vagues étaient ils peuvent être
maîtrisés qu'on laisse pas gars qui sont
cuits advent là c'est al dente chef
ok les gars de mon vécu et enfin que
c'est une phase cruciale crucial oh là
là en cage
on monte d'un cran dans la tension est
apte à vous chez lui pareille à vous
écouter bien le chef pour neininger état
crucial tuer ton coeur uni en faire et
tu commences avec garde jean cau la
moitié des 2 et j'arrête mes copains
font chuter buveurs je laisse sur le sol
pardon chef dans leur aventure
ça y est puis avec le fait qu'on prépare
parce que fais tu m'as tu vu plein
du coup on est parent ait avalé 3 cafés
qui commencent à fuir oui j'ai commencé
à fuir la moitié à peu près la pitié de
la préparation
voilà peut-être que la sienne elle est
un peu court peut-être que la terne le
collectif alors qu'il faut qu'il arrête
un peu moins chaud pas d'accord cher et
il croit que moi j'ai juste et mes yeux
j'y prends l'air un peu les risques et
d'ajouter un petit souci feu de feu mais
toulouse mans ont laissé beaucoup d'amis
les motifs sur le ce ben voilà images
riches imagine que c'est ils voient bien
que c'est à lui de faire sauter ne sais
pas c'est pas gagné mais bon on
progressé 1 g vous essayez de faire
conter l'espagne dating comme le chef
est très très difficile a fait mais on
essaye
j'aime bien courir
environ connaissons pas ce que cissokho
est prêt après des crises ils sont pas
une fatalité
d'accord alors du coup et intercepte à
côté oui j'ai mes assiettes je vais les
apporter au thé dire c'est fin c'est pas
qu'il recettes faciles à réaliser
il faut jusque il faut que la cour ait
vraiment quelquefois au combat
philatélique parce que c'est plus que
c'est tout un équilibre entre la
puissance des spaghettis la python 2 2
pourquoi que les juges un conflit qui va
faire une idée du brouillés et pourquoi
que les autres sont trop cool non plus
c'est vraiment celui qui avec les fonds
à wisches s alors est ce que tu peux me
dire si au niveau de la cuisse atsem le
bien et je m'en vais car elle que je
vais me garder
la puissance a l'air bien a fait tout ça
c'est la somme que cet élève un peu
démarre deux ans vraiment alors je
commence à dresser mais pas gâté tu vas
là est leur chef
j'ai trouvé un cercle ouais c'est pas
donc c'est donc on va dresser les
spaghettis on avait le tour demain c'est
à dire que là il me faut la louche ça te
permettra vraiment aidé présenté en
manière élégante 1
l important alors je vais prendre la
fourchette et essayer de tourner tu as
fait dans la louche sur un boss patrick
amoah là à bonnart elle doit vraiment
consistante généreuse comme ça moi
j'aime pas les pas que des conditions
trop et la fourche est trop et trop et
donc on vient rappeler le reste les
pecorino là et le grand chalet qu'on
avait mis une poule la pancetta con agua
elle sur le sopalin exactement quand on
a une petite voix me faire des crocs
compte construire la fin oui c'est
superbe parce qu'effectivement c'est un
petit peu un petit tout petit peu grillé
croustillant ça fait maintenant les
factures de magie qui enlève le faire et
les gardois ça doit donner c'est doit
donner ses côtés par ruse
tu vois il faut vraiment qu'il ya de la
sauce de la générosité d'alès pas gâcher
ta bonnart a pas ce que nous disions
dans une chose qui est trop loin dès que
les spaghettis répandit dans un peu ils
sont immangeables
et moi je termine je termine avec un
public et des poivres les points que
j'avais je vais pas me au départ pour
les rondes est vraiment bien alors je
comprends on prend une pincée du poivre
là les promenades avec wayne ait pas
beaucoup d'abeilles projet qu'il fallait
donc un petit peu de poivre
et voilà ça sent très très très bon
alors je trouve je trouve que tu as pas
gâté il manque un peu de liquidités
liquidités d'accord il faut qu'il soit
les garde fous que tu sois un peu d'une
heureuse tu vois la sauce là faut que tu
sois généreuse avec ma chaise je vois
chez j'aurais dû mettre un peu plus de
stock alors on peut on peut rattraper ça
en rajoutant la sauce bien sûr différent
voilà ce que j'en ai
j'en ai de la sauce donc donc là je
viens de prendre
j'ai personnellement c'est c'est pour ça
que c'est important d'avoir ces fonds un
crayon le brunch al parce que les
volcans leïla un réseau de gens c'était
que les grandes salles il ya encore
cette fois je n'ai pas que le plus
important que la pancetta est pas ce
qu'ils font et feront de komi roffidal à
poil
il m'a donné ces petites grand combat
les mules signer avec les défis sont
dits oui tu sais je pense qu'elle a
maintenant tu as des bases maintenant et
y atteint d'une très belle
qu'est-ce qu'il faut que tu penses
maintenant c'est de prendre les tons et
de les réveiller plusieurs fois pour
vraiment à la fin avoir entre ses côtes
et toi maman est grossier 18 ans
d'écriture qu'elle a un côté
croustillantes et du one charlet salle à
côté généreux des yeux et surtout
prendre des fermes des yeux bio parce
que du coup les yeux qui sont à moitié
cuit
ne prenez pas de risques aux deux écrans
industrielle est très important que la
chute je te laisse la dégustation et
tutelle à 8 h pour un commentaire qui
disent des gens chez eux dans leur
cuisine qui ont déjà commencé à goûter à
l'or h f je vais goûter un corps
retrouvé la recette sur lefigaro.fr
comme ça vous avez tous les ingrédients
et ses délicieuses et ses puissants
volumes sur scène c'est délicat parce
que tu as vraiment ses coups de patte
shehata qui est au rendez vous de ces
bouts de voir avec un rob white et ce
poivre ce choix leur compteur qu'on a
qu'on a écrasé de façon pas banal avec
le avec le dos d'une casserole vraiment
mal commencé très bon moi d'habitude
franchement et on mange un petit entrer
hoarau en dessert après entre 80 et 100
grand départ c'est largement suffisant
avait fait très beau sur les très grands
en fait en avoir la sueur chef simone
zanoni merci beaucoup de ta gentillesse
mais reviennent avec les mots hésiter
merci beaucoup
bon appétit
grasset